and comes out what you saw and all that
stuff i think yeah i think he lived it
did you watch it uh no just like that i
think he lived up to the hype you know
he came out
ranked number 11 jumping all the way to
two which is unheard of yeah so
obviously he's he's as advertised as the
test
but his coach you know i mean chin
talked about on the shop show his coach
came out and said like
you know people asking what i said
during the second round like i tore into
them like dude quit [ __ ] fighting
like you're in a street fight like use
your length make it boring yeah use your
reach like he was he had no game plan
you're just in there to fight yeah and
when you get to a certain level and
thank god it worked against gilbert but
that ain't working against colby or
camaro you gotta you have to have a game
plan so that is the fight him and colby
next or whatever uh that's what dana
wants like dana said colby and hans out
of fight on abc
the issue with that is uh kobe wants to
get paid
like they're gonna happen and that's not
a big payday for him no it'd be a big
payday especially on abc hopefully they
would up his pay but he just demands
more money so there's going to be a bit
you should demand more money yeah but
the problem with that is you'll see okay
we'll have somebody else fight him you
don't want to do it on abc but i hope
they figure it out because dude colby
who's the ultimate heel is going to be
usa versus russia
oh my god he's going to
do he's going to offend everybody yeah
and take my money even though it's free
on abc but take my money colby correct
because there's nobody better to play
this game and also you know before that
fight hamza didn't have any [ __ ] in his
armor nobody wanted to fight him that's
why i had to fight them too guy they
didn't want to give him number two but
nobody would find it oh [ __ ] so
gilbert's like i'll do it so ufc is like
[ __ ] it let's see what happens he passed
the test
but you know i think if you're colby or
camaro now you're going i'll fight that
guy for five rounds
because that fourth and fifth can get
dicey for me especially fights like that
so if you're a hamza fan which i am you
gotta hope he learned from that and like
oh i can't fight like this all the time
and also i think you overlook gilbert
because he's sitting on the cage
chilling i'm like whoa dude number two
guy for a reason i said it yeah you said
it i was like watching him kick talk and
i'm like you don't look like you're
you're taking gilbert burns lightly
i know like you don't get to be number
two like without nobody dude he just
he's not that far
uh you know when he was fighting
tomorrow he's been for a world
championship and rock tomorrow yeah he
did i watched that fight before uh this
one yeah no he's not yeah and and
homside hasn't really done much in the
ufc so to me i was like ah man he's kind
of buying the hype yeah and his coach
said that he's like
his coach yeah his coach said that he's
like we had a game plan he just fought
like scrapped like you're just trying to
scrap and you can't do that but thank
god he passed you know he got passed
yeah 2019. so how do you think he would
do against colby then it'd be
if if that if he did the exact same
thing he did on saturday night yeah yeah
kobe beats him by decision
but i don't think he will i think he'll
learn from him and get better
so we'll see damn it's fun though yeah
who's the better striker
comes up
probably right it's
tough to no i don't know colby's can
[ __ ] strike with them
do it he can do anything he has a gas
tank for days you're not taking colby
down never been taken down you're not
taking him down no
all-american from oregon state coe's a
monster
uh yeah yeah so you know
but but i think if hamza uses reach it
won't be the most exciting fight it's
all right but you can win dude yeah
but if that same hamza showed up against
camaro colby he wouldn't he wouldn't it
comes out of natural 85
i don't know like gilbert's a pretty
juicy 170 pounder but it's not like com
that the hamsa had reach and
uh hide but he wasn't like
no well he looked skinny actually i mean
he wasn't like finn yeah yeah so they
were just gonna beat up both but i just
think it's interesting my my larger
question is when he would he's got that
great jab and he exchanged
up and then when when he would in the
transition so boom boom boom he get hit
when he looks right
that's what he said right i went you're
resetting but you don't you're getting
caught he's still in the pocket yes
you're getting caught in the pocket so
so bob bob he would he would like
counter and then uh gilbert would come
back with that and he was getting
clipped almost everywhere that's what
his coach said like you shouldn't be in
there dude right you should be outside
using your reach and height advantage
right which he didn't and that's what
that the game plan was right that's what
it's called don't stand in the pocket
coach was so upset right
damn yeah i wonder why he went in this
coach said use your reach okay do you
think that peter young won that fight i
heard a lot of people no not at all no
no and what now again i went
balls deep in this on the shop showing
the paint on it's it's no i have no ill
will towards dana but when dana is
watching at cage side and then does the
press conference and goes they got it
wrong on that one without watching it
like we see it
again you're you [ __ ] your champion over
now there's still that yeah dark cloud
over al jamaica now you didn't really
beat him even your boss didn't think you
did it's not al jermaine beat him i
watched i watched it this morning i
watched it yesterday out so the way you
break that fight down
is it's five rounds right first round is
the the deciding factor the sound factor
second round clearly
clearly
i'm not even close yeah to me that's why
i even said you could do 10 8 if you
want i'm not mad at you 1080 so dominic
ten eight
third round you i wouldn't give him a
108 only because he had him had his back
but he didn't do a lot he didn't do a
lot of damage sure but he just dominated
yes like he'd literally dominate the
entire round third round dominate and
tie around so second third there's no
argument anybody on the planet knows he
won't say third uh fourth
yawn all day for sure yeah fifth close
but you let's give it to peter so it's
all in the first [ __ ] round yeah the
first round based off the scoring
criteria
people are going to give it to yon going
octagon control aggressiveness yeah but
what's his name hold on
but that's the that's the
the like big john had to break because i
used to always say that too here's the
aggressor this big john goes hold up
that's the last thing that you judge of
brown off of is octagon control right
before that there must be damage done
strikes landed so i'm going based off
the
we're jacksonville florida commission
where they do judging based off their
judging which is what we have the only
way to go off of
al germain landed more strikes
actually no uh period allen had a more
significant strike bring that up gin he
did he landed two kills he won like he
landed he won the 40. he landed two kids
yeah but 51 to 46 i think but but but
having said that al jermaine tried to
take him down 22 times to zero
but that's you're talking about the
overall fight i'm talking about just the
first round okay that's all we care
about oh i got you this whole fight is
predicated on oh let's see
and that's why i'm saying algerian did
more in the first round he's more active
oh wow you can't go oh well he was on
his back foot the whole round well i
agree that doesn't that's that's his
style 100 you can't base the round off
that
that's interesting yeah the first round
then so
so two judges had it for sterling in the
first round of course
but they don't but uh do copy strike
numbers for that first round
chin okay
[Music]
is copy strike
stats
is that it right there tim it's a second
it's just all japanese but i'll check it
out oh
here we are yeah
so first round strikes
so so
uh yeah well that's overall though
so strikes
is six two six three take down two two
you gotta give it so you you gotta
ultimately but i need it by the round
you know what i'm saying
is that here we go
so red's al germain so round one he
landed 19 of 40. wow john landed 13 of
26.
so
again i'm going off the florida state
commission that's a win rules uh-huh
look at this so he landed more did more
damage more significant strikes 17 of 29
so 58 percent of strikes to the body
that's second round to
that second round two yeah
and then
i'm sorry
why are you going off why do you have to
go up the first round because everything
else is clear as day oh god second third
is al germain the fourth is john all day
fifth close but let's give it to yon so
young won two out of three it's very
evident
but again what [ __ ] al jermaine is dana
gunn judge got wrong on that one without
looking at the actual numbers just being
kate's side watching on that little
shitty screen it's like dude you [ __ ]
them now now the same narrative you're
not the real champion when the guy
deserves it he beat him yeah
based off of i agree your calculation is
your judging criteria al james one
minute huge 35
that would be yeah i would be interested
in seeing algerman going up to 45 and
fighting uh
our boy uh volcano what do you think of
that
he's not that big of a 35 but
santa hagan's a big 35 i feel like he's
bigger than san diego he's not as tall
saying he's taller but he's thick
especially in that fight he looked thick
it's tough you always want people to go
up b and it's tough man you know it's
tough
because you have to you have to talk
about the stretch the strength advantage
and there's also there's a lot of work
for them to do at 35.
you just got the belt and barely got it
yeah
because you click the only the only time
you're going to jump is if you're like
conor mcgregor or izzy and you're just
dominating and you're like a massive
star or you've cleaned out the division
yeah there's a lot of work to do yeah
you know there are a lot of killers he
can't jump he's got a face [ __ ] tj
dylan
tj's fighting next right yeah
that's a great fight who's he fighting
tj dillashaw
made of different cloth
yeah i can't wait